hello everyone and welcome back to the
fiji world cup 2021 now we have a very
nice game between sasha martinez
the uh current creation champion and the
magnus carlson of course the world
champion
and the magnus doesn't really need to
play this tournament because mostly we
want to play it
to win the spot in the next candidate
cycle uh so two of the
the the top ranked players in the in
this tournament will be
getting direct access to defeat a
candidate's tournament for
uh for the next cycle and if you don't
know affida announced
the criteria for how to enter the
candidates tournament a few a few months
back i think
so one spot will be the feeder
wheelchair championship match runner-up
so
after magnus faces yanny pomnyshi now in
november
even if magnus loses he will still get a
direct
placement into the candidates tournament
for for the next cycle
so one spot uh will not be the person
with the highest rating but
this time the uh this spot goes to temur
rajabov
because rajab of um gave up his place in
the candidates you know due to kovid and
everything and then maksim took his
place
but now we will have our job of in the
next candidates tournament uh for those
of you who may may not have known this
so two spots will be given to the uh
well
to the players who perform best at
affiliate world cup which is this
tournament two spots will be
feedahs.com grand swiss tournament also
from 2021 and two spots defeated grand
prix series as
they always do in 2022 so without
further ado let's check out this game
martino which has the white pieces and
it's quite
quite a nice um a nice positional game
so he goes for d4
we have knight to f6 by magnus c for g6
knight to c3 and d5 magnus goes for the
groomfield defense here
we have c characters knight captures and
now i'm not going for the immediate e4
bishop to d2 first
and now this is not oh e4 is the most
common play the bishop to d2 is the
second most common play but also very
very
uh very much playable and here black
mostly goes bishop g7 or he just shifts
the knight back to
b6 but now magnus goes for c5 and it's a
move that's only been played in a
handful of games so he's trying to
surprise
martino each here we have rook to c1
you could also capture it white will
definitely capture this at some point
and then black will play bishop g7
castles
and black will have a very nice rapid
development where white still has to
play a few moves to get
his king to safety so instead after this
uh c5 move we have rook to c1
uh and now knight to c6 we have d
captures in c5 and magnus continues with
bishop to g7
and now there are a few games where
knight to f3 was played but here we have
e4 and it is now already
as of mov8 that we have a completely new
game so let's see how magnus
deals with this he doesn't capture on c3
he plays knight to b4 now kind of puts
pressure on the a2 pawn but not really
you never want to give up this bishop
just to grab this pawn
uh it's simply to to too great of a
piece so knight to f3
and here magnus castles with a3 now
challenging this knight
and the knight now goes to d3 delivering
checks so white of course are very happy
to eliminate this knight
bishop captures queen captures and now
the queen prevents the white king from
castling so you have to
deal with this somehow either by playing
queen c2 maybe queen e2
maybe bishop e3 maybe you defend this
pawn over a queen trade then maybe later
on you can push b
for b5 uh you know a lot of ways to deal
with this
so he plays queen to e2 and magnus very
happily trades with queen captures king
captures
uh and now bishop to e6 with some ideas
of grabbing more space bishop to c for
check would be would be very nice
but also bishop to b3 might come in
handy at some point
so here knight to d5 blocking the light
square bishop but also offering the b2
pawn
uh for some uh for some activity so
bishop captures on b2
and now sasha plays rook the seat you
attacking the bishop thinking that
magnus will just go back with the bishop
since you can't really capture on a3 as
rook to a1 would trap the bishop
but this is exactly what magnus does he
plays a bishop captures an a3
and now comes rook to a1 and it seems
like carlson's bishop is trapped here
but there is one move that he can play
to get out of this mess so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find
this move for black
the only good move for black while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on being a true
master of the position and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is of course
f5 and f5 now shows that there's no way
for white to actually claim the the
material advantage because black is
threatening
upon captures here and then this knight
will be under attack and also this
knight will be under attack so you don't
really gain anything by
by capturing the bishop but there there
isn't really anything better
uh for example if you try and knight the
c7 which seems like a good idea attacks
the rook here and the bishop on e6
that's undefended
after everything settles down let's say
if captures on e4 we're gonna capture on
e6 of course you're gonna grab the piece
not the exchange
so knight captures an e6 now e captures
on f3 comes with
check and after g captures rook f3 now
goes after the knight and now after this
uh bishop is captured we're going to
capture the knight with checking to f1
and now if you count everything it's
magnus who's up a pawn but also he has a
much better pawn structure a white has a
double f pawn so black's position should
be
uh with perfect play i i i don't know if
if it would be winning but it would be
very very hard to play this especially
against someone like magnus
so instead of this after f5 we have rook
captures on a3 right away
f captures on e4 now both of the knights
are under attack and now
you have to give up one of them so you
might as well get something for it so
knight captures on e7
grabs back upon knight captures and now
knight to d for going after the bishop
here
but just bishop to d7 at some point uh
you want to play a6 and the b7 pawn will
be
uh will be a liability so we want to
play this bishop to c6 so here
the rook to b2 attacking the b7 pawn but
magnus just goes knight to c6
attacks the knight and also if the
knights are traded out then bishop
captures here magnus gets exactly what
he wanted
so instead we have bishop to e3 now
comes knight
captures on d4 with czech bishop
captures and bishop to c6 so defending
the b7 pawn also defending the e4 pawn
and uh magnus now is up upon in this
very very interesting end game
but it's bishops of opposite colors so
if sasha can get the rooks off the board
could be
it could be you know it might be
possible to prevent uh magnus from
winning this
uh and magnus will of course try to do
everything in his power to prevent this
so here we have rook beat the a2 now
threatening the a7 pawn
now a6 we have king to e3 but now
rook 8 to d8 and now you could uh
with black you could maybe double up on
the d file you could also double up on
the f file
all depends on what white plays so here
we have rook to d2
but now rook to d5 again both doubling
on the f and on the d
file are possible so all depends on what
white
white plays we have kink to eq and now
rook f2 f2d8 putting pressure on the
bishop here
so bishop to e3 now offering a trade of
everything but
magnus just plays rook to d3 and it's a
very sneaky idea because if sasha grabs
this rook captures on d3 we're just
gonna capture it with this pawn
and we get the nice pass pawn here since
you can't capture it bishop to b5
uh wins the game for black so instead
after rook d3 we have rook to a1
and here king to f7 magnus just slowly
starts bringing his king into the game
we have g3
and now rook captures on d2 we have
bishop captures and now
bishop to b5 with check we have king to
e1
now comes rook to d3 and you can see
even though it's bishops of opposite
colors
black's position is much much better
magnus has all of his pawns on light
squares assassin has all of his pawns on
dark squares so the bishops cannot
attack them
the problem is white has no way of
activating his king the rook covers the
entire third rank
and there is no way of activating
anything the king can be activated the
bishop is useless since
absolutely everything magnus has is on a
light square and the rook of course
cannot enter the game via any open file
since the only open file on the board is
controlled by magnus
and magnus has a pretty clear plan he's
going to bring the king into the game
and then win the c5 pawn
uh the problem is or maybe not but he's
gonna
well if he's not gonna be able to win
the c5 pawn then he will be able to do
something else but
that's how chess works so for example
rook to b1 was played
with king the e6 magnus just starts
bringing the king in
rook to b4 we have bishop to c6 now
defending this pawn
uh rook to b2 bringing the rook back but
now just king to e5 and he was in this
position i don't know 34
that sasha resigned the game as there
really isn't all that much to do here
for white you could of course uh put up
more resistance but
he decided to turn in the towel and try
uh
better with the black pieces because two
games are played
in the video world cup so he will get a
chance uh to retaliate with the black
pieces now
the problem is you can't really stop
black from
uh you know just just moving forward if
you try some like rook a2
uh we're gonna play king to d5 if you
play rook back to c2 we're gonna play
bishop to b5 now we're gonna
play bishop to c4 and we're gonna cut
off the rook's defense of the pawn and
try to win it and then for example let's
say h3
we're gonna play bishop c4 we're gonna
try and win the pawn if bishop to e3 now
defends the pawn
now we start advancing this pawn because
the bishop now moved here we
he allowed us this square the bishop
covers a2 the recovers a3 so we're just
going to push this pawn and it's going
to be
it's going to be a very swift victory
for so although you could make uh
why uh black's life a bit hard
in the end magnus will prevail here
sasha of course knows this and after
king to e5 he
resigned the game uh so yeah very very
very nicely done we'll see if magnus
will be able to win this uh
like i said he doesn't uh even if he
loses the world chase championship to
nippo he doesn't really need to
uh to qualify via the the affiliate
world cup or anything since he has an
auto he
since he will automatically be seated
into the candidates tournament as the
run run but still
uh he decided to play and maybe
eliminate some of the
more serious contenders from the uh 2021
uh 2022 feeder candidates tournament
but all in all uh seems like he's having
a good time here with the black pieces
so let's see
let's see what happens in the other
games and of course keep using hashtag
hashtag suggestion this suggests more
very nice games
so once again i hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank christopher
martis kaminsky
peter grieve francis uh air and tom
darrell for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
world cup checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day